ساذهب الان الى قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه من جده مع مراسلنا هاني صفيان الذي
يرصد وصول طائره اندونيسيه تجري رعاياها
من السودان هاني ما هو المشهد لديك
الاجواء لديك
نعم نعم اهلا بك ميسون واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه اذا من قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه في القطاع الغربي وتحديدا من مدينه
جده وصول الطائره من نوع بوينج 705 تحمل
42 شخص من الرعايه
اندونيسيا وكذلك
الاضافه الى 13 شخص من ايضا الرعايه
بريطانيا عفوا استراليا وهناك ايضا بعض
الجنسيات التي قد تتضح معنا خلال او من
عند نزولهم سوف نلاحظ ذلك ولكن هذه هي
الصور الاولى واللحظات الاولى لوصول هؤلاء
الرعايه الذين قدموا للتو من السودان طبعا
دعيني في البدايه نرى حجم الطائره انه
نلاحظ ان حجم الطائره هي من نوع بوينج 705
وهي صغيره جدا لانها تلائم المدرج الذي
منه وهو ما تحدثنا اليه يوم امس ان المط
او المطار بورسودان هو مطار قصير او
المجررج فيه قصير فلا يلائم جميع الطائرات
طبعا هذه الطائره تتبع للقوات الجويه
الاندونيسيه فهناك ايضا طائره اخرى من
المتوقع ان تصل وهي من نوع ايضا عسكريه
اندونيسيه من نوع سي13 ولكن الطائره الان
هي التي وصلت من نوع بوينج 305 وتحمل 42
شخص على متنها طبعا الرئيس او عفوا هناك
قيادات عسكريه وكذلك القنصل العام
الاندونيسي ايكو هارتونو الذي تحدث لنا ان
هناك
787 مواطنا اندونيسيا وصلوا حتى هذه
اللحظه الى جده
وجميعهم قدمهم من السودان منهم 385
شخصا غادروا الى اندونيسيا اجمالي الجاليه
الاندونيسيه الموجوده في السودان هم الف
شخص وهذه دفعه جديده يتوقع ايضا ان تصل
دفعه اخرى ويكتمل العدد الكامل وبذلك يصبح
او تصبح اندونيسيا ليس لها او لديها رعايه
في السودان وتصبح اول دوله تخلي كافه
تصبح ثاني دوله تخلي رعاياها جميعا من
السودان بعد السعوديه
ما هي الاليه المستخدمه من اجل انهاء
الاوراق ومن اجل يعني مكوثهم حتى مغادرتهم
اراضي جده
هناك المرحله التاليه لو نلاحظ ايضا الان
هناك
وصلوا او دخول الرعايه الذين وصلوا الى
الصاله المعده لهم وبعد ذلك يتم استلام
جوازاتهم ومنحهم تاشيره دخول طارئه لان
معظمهم لا يحمل تاشيره الدخول الى
السعوديه
فيعطى له من قبل الجوازات السعوديه تاشيره
دخول وبعد ذلك يتم نقله الى الحافله وبعد
الحافله يتم نقلهم الى مقر اقامتهم
الفندقيه وبعدها يتم الترتيب مع القنصليه
الاندونيسيه ليتم مغادرتهم من جده الى
بلادهم اندونيسيا طبعا في مثل هذه الحالات
الان هي
معظم لا يملك ولا يحمل التاشيره الدخول
الى السعوديه فيجب اعطائه او منحني هذه
التاشيره حتى يتمكن من الدخول الى الاراضي
السعوديه وكذلك مغادر بكل سلام وكذلك امان
عموما عمليات الجسر الجوي لعمليات الاجرام
مستمره ليس فقط هنا في قاعده الملك عبد
الله الجويه ايضا على البحر ما زالت
عمليات الاجلاء سواء عبر القوات عبر
القوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه او كذلك
عبر الفرقات العسكريه الاجنبيه وعبر ايضا
السفن التجاريه الاجنبيه التي ما زالت
ايضا تقوم بحمل وايضا نقل رعاياها من
بوتسودان الى جده طبعا جده هي المنطقه
القريبه تبعد عن بورسودان قرابه البيئه
وثمانين ميلا اين نتحدث قرابه الثلاثه
كيلو متر وهي اقرب منطقه واوفر منطقه
عموما هناك تواصل مستمر بين الخارجيه
السعوديه والحكومه السعوديه وبايضا بين
السفرات والقنصليات التي ترغب
بنقل رعاياها معظم ما شاهدناه وما رصدته
ايضا كاميراتنا او كاميره العربيه تحديدا
ان هذه معظم الدول تنقل فقط رايها
باستثناء القوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه
والقوات الجويه الملكيه السعوديه عبر
طائرات السي وان تنقل رايه من جنسيات
مختلفه وكذلك
يعطى لهم مثل ما يعطى للرعايه الاخرين منح
تاشيره طارئه وكذلك ايضا
تسهيل مهمتهم لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات